suddenly we find that especially with
kovid and the Ukrainian war that
suddenly the the world is breaking up
and everybody's looking you know what
side they should be on
they could pretend that you know it's us
in the United States we run the world
and now all of a sudden you wake up one
morning
and you realize that you're just a you
know a large Regional power and I think
for for those people a lot of those
people
that came as a bit of a shock and they
basically began to sort of blame the
West for the predicament they were in
you know you can't blame the war on this
single individual there's a whole system
at play there it's a lot of interests
that are work and if Putin is taken out
then somebody else will replace him who
might uh smile a little bit more than
Putin does but essentially things will
pretty much remain the same one of my
fears you know is not just simply what
Russia is doing in Ukraine
one of my fears is what will happen if
Russia implodes the Federation implodes
because
in the Russian Federation is by no means
as coherent and stable as it looks I'm a
lot of the republics you know sort of
exists within the Russian Federation or
dying to get out of that Federation
they're all looking somewhere else
hey Francis do you like journalism of
course so who's your favorite journalist
then Superman what Superman Superman
isn't a real person Francis he's an
alien he's not a journalist and more
importantly he's [ __ ] fictional mate
if he was fictional then why did
Frederick nature wrote about Superman
otherwise known as ubermench in his
seminal work Thus Spoke zarathustra
published in 1883 but still widely
quoted today by both students and
intellectuals alike sometimes Francis I
feel as if I have no clue who you really
are but if you do like journalism then
you have to check out the epoch times
the epoch times unlike most media
organizations is produced without the
influence of any government corporation
or political party they distill a story
down to the fact and get readers as
close to the truth as they can the
articles are free from the influence of
big Tech corporate media and socialist
and Communist forces as well the epoch
times believe the more facts you have at
your disposal the better able you are to
preserve your rights here's what the
readers say about them the Articles
present a factual picture of the news
from a conservative and American
perspective I feel the epoch times is
the only publication out there that
gives me factual information about
stories in the news that other outlets
and Publications blatantly Report with
liberal political biases go to
epocttim.es forward slash trigonometry
and and click the link that's Epoch Tim
e p o c h t i m dot e s slash
trigonometry
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with Fascinating People
our brilliant guest today is an Emeritus
professor at the University of Kent and
a prolific author not least of his
latest book which is this the road to
Ukraine How the West lost its way Frank
ferreti welcome to trigonometry real
pleasure to talk to you guys uh we've
been meaning to have you on for a while
and uh this is a good opportunity to do
that before we get into talking about
your latest book tell everybody who are
you how are you where you are what has
been uh your journey through life leads
you to be sitting here talking to us
well it All Began in 1956 in the
Hungarian Revolution
where my parents and I were very active
fighting the Russians and decided to
leave and the Revolution was crushed
ended up in Canada I grew up in Canada
where I studied politics and decided to
come to London to do my PhD the plan was
to go back to Canada but I I just kind
of never went back I realized I was a
European
and got involved in radical left
politics at that stage in time of
student radical
I'm one of those 60s persons that has no
regrets I really enjoyed you know those
years a real good fun and then gradually
with the passing of time they will
change I find myself being drawn more
and more in slightly different direction
than even a greater Direction
towards becoming much more interested in
Old classical liberal ideas
and at the end of the day I'm became
very active politically and commented on
political cultural issues
whilst being a professor at the
University
and today I've got the honor of of being
called in any day of the week a Marxist
by some people that are Fascist by other
people
but I just think I'm a regular guy you
know sort of with strong views well
welcome to the club I think we all can't
hold that when was the last time you
were called the Marxist mate yeah uh
exactly yeah that is that doesn't happen
to me to us too much a left-wing show
yes neoliberal so that's just what your
girlfriend calls you anyway uh Frank
you've got a book out uh smooth as that
transition is which called the road to
Ukraine uh and uh one of the things you
talk about is our inability to
understand the role of the past in
forming the present and you talk about
how this conflict has its roots in World
War one which let's be honest wasn't
covered heavily in the mainstream media
news coverage of of this conflict so
take it away
well the way that I look at it is that
in the first World War
everything became disrupted in Europe
particularly
well all over the world so you had the
Russian Revolution that kind of kicked
in as a result of that the breakup of
the different Empire or the Austrian
Empire the
Ottoman Empire the German Empire they're
all kind of disintegrated
and this led to us a chain of events
where all kinds of national ethnic
conflicts
became very very important they were all
unresolved which meant that nobody was
surprised when the second world war
broke out
and people thought well that might bring
things to an end history is probably
going to become easier from here onwards
but then the Cold War kicked in
and what happened was that when the Cold
War finished and in particular when the
Soviet Union disintegrated
a lot of people people imagined that
that's history and that's the past I
mean not even a new world
and they imagined that you know they had
this uh fantasy that somehow Europe was
going to become peaceful books were
written with the title of how Wars had
become obsolete Hall we're not going to
have harmonious existence the Germans in
particular imagined that they could
somehow seduce the Russians by through
economic trade that somehow economic
trade would lead to democracy and it
would lead to the liberalization of
cultural life both in China and in
Russia
and then all of a sudden we realized
that Wars you know which were not
supposed to happen are very real and are
very contemporary and what I'm arguing
in the book is that by forgetting what
history was about I called historical
amnesia
we somehow lost our way and uh failed to
realize that there is a a legacy there
there's a burden of history there
that we've got to engage with a little
bit more uh sort of creatively than
we've been doing at the moment otherwise
we're going to be called unaware as we
did when when Russia invaded the Ukraine
isn't part of the problem Frank I know
Constantine always talks about this is
that we believe in the west that
everybody thinks like us and the reality
is that they don't they have they see
the world in a different way they have
different goals
and as a result they're going to do
different things
I think that's true and that need not be
a problem I don't think there's any need
for everybody
to kind of talk to the same script
uh so I got no problem with that and
when you go to Russia or when you go to
east Europe there's something nice in
their particular interpretation of the
world the way they see things but I
think what is the problem was uh was
imagining that somehow
through the imperative of the market and
through economic relations
that somehow
consumerism and capitalism would seduce
everybody
to become just like we are and that's
something that would transcend their
historical and cultural Legacy and not
really understand that when you sit down
with a Russian or a Polish person or a
Latvian person you're talking to
somebody who sees the world from a very
different perspective than somebody
living in Manchester
I'm Frank so how is that manifested we
talked let's come back to World War one
because you've got these huge Empires
that collapse they leave a lot of uh
simmering National conflicts how is that
related to the war in Ukraine I mean I
think I have an interpretation but to
tell our audience well I think that the
Ukraine became this battlefield for
competing national interests
and during the 20th century it was
dominated and invaded by a variety of
different nations from the Germans to
the Russians to the Czechs the
hungarians went in there as well
and the Ukraine wasn't really a nation
you know in in The Sovereign sense of
the term until much much later even
though in a very strong national
movement in in the Ukraine that
hoped that after the first world war
Ukraine would be given uh
self-determination
the Russians the Soviet government
promised them this new Ukrainian
Federation which would be almost like a
nation but it really wasn't
but what's interesting is that when you
go to Ukraine it is it it is like a very
layered Society with different
historical interests in it and I
remember because I started off the book
with my trip to the Ukraine the Ukraine
and I was really walking around in a
place in a place in transcorpasia which
I heard so much about from my parents
and there are these different layers you
see you know like you go to the church
and on the church door it says there are
there's a Mass for in in Slovakian on
Monday uh on Tuesday we have we have a
mask for the hungarians on Wednesdays
for ukrainians and it's even now it's
got these different layers of historical
influences and I felt that when I went
into Ukraine I just stepped into history
it really had a an emotional
psychologically you know sort of uh
unexpected impact on me because I felt
that I was time traveling I was going
back and forth in my at least in my own
head because I was seeing traces of the
past everywhere that I went that were
not always Ukrainian but the Ukrainian
was in there and I could really
understand why it is
the Ukraine had this very difficult
predicament and is going to have that
difficult predicament unfortunately for
some time to come
and you say that and we're looking at
the first world war what are the other
parallels that you see between what
happened with the first world war and
the current situation Frank
well I I think there I think uh the main
parallel with with then and now is not
so much the first world war but the
years leading up to it because the years
leading up to it was I'm talking about
essentially from about 19 10 to 14. were
years when the old order was breaking
down
you know we had this golden era in
Europe and all of a sudden that golden
era was coming to an end yet internal
domestic tensions you had can I just
stop you there because I don't think a
lot of people will know about this what
do you mean by a golden era in the early
20th century well the late Victorian era
ends in the 19th century and if you go
anywhere in Central Europe you'll find
these beautiful buildings uh and they
were all essentially built between
1890 and 1905 roughly because that's
really where that when due to the
Industrial Revolution due to the
economic relative economic Prosperity
not for everybody but for the middle
classes really began to kick in that's
the beginning of what we call consumer
Society in Europe and everybody's saying
this is really incredible now some
Bohemians feel upset because life's too
easy and they you have the new Avon gold
kind of emerging at that time but by and
large this was a an unprecedented era of
peace I mean decades and Decades of
peace in inverted common in Europe and
why does it start to break down I think
it begins to break down because uh
National tensions and rivalries
principally between Britain and Germany
but then also with within that kind of
context you have a lot of conflicts
begin to emerge and nobody knows who is
going to be on what side because until
that point Britain the British Empire is
the hegemonic power in the global it's
losing its economic muscles
so what you then have is a situation
where for example new alliances get
created and nobody knows who's going to
be award snack so just to give you an
example
you know sort of when the when the war
breaks out Italy is not yet clear you
know whether they're going to be on the
side of the austro-hungarian Empire and
and and and Germany or whether they're
going to be with England and France and
America and the very last minute they
change and you have all these you know
Turks begin to change everybody's
positioning themselves
and so you have this you know this kind
of world that you cannot predict how
it's going to unfold and to me the
situation today is very similar in the
sense that that ethos of globalization
that we were led to believe would last
forever
where National interest and the nation's
stateful diminishing significantly
suddenly we find that especially with
kovid and and the Ukrainian war that
certainly the the world is breaking up
and everybody's looking you know what
side they should be on and people who
wonder whether you know Taiwan should be
defended or not defended people are
wondering whether Europe should make an
effort to pull together or you know are
the Germans and the French is going to
go their own way so it's a very kind of
fluid Dynamic situation
and it just so happens that in the
middle of that you've got this war in
the Ukraine and it just so happened in
the middle of that we discovered this
week that uh Armenia and Azerbaijan
which are not small in significant
states are filing a little mini War
a kind of a sideshow which could turn
out to be even more significant
than the war in the Ukraine itself
and it's interesting when we're talking
about that because
you're talking about you know the the
Decades of peace and prosperity and it
seems that well it doesn't seem that's
what we've enjoyed here do you think
that that people get lulled into a sense
of security thinking that you know
there's good times nobody's at War
therefore we've eliminated War
I think there is that problem uh
particularly in the anglo-american world
and in the book I talk about the
geopolitical illiteracy that you have in
Britain where you're before in office
where I meet guys from the foreign
office and they don't speak a foreign
language really yeah absolutely yeah I
mean the phone office was famous
for their you know Arab speakers the
times last week reported
that we haven't got enough Mandarin
speakers in the foreign office and this
is obviously a very serious matter
because China is one of our the big
issues of our time
so we have this geopolitical literacy
right people are not very good at
anticipating and calculating and I think
that that kind of our Elites have become
uniquely ineffective in dealing with
geopolitical issues
and what is the role of the Cold War and
the post-cold war period and what's
happened because uh the you know people
argue that I mean I I have some
difficulty with this argument but do
people do make the argument that you
know Russia wasn't treated the way it
should have been treated after the
collapse of the Soviet Union do we
needed a Marshall Plan we needed to help
Russia onto its feet and later in fact
NATO started to encroach on Russia's
strategic interest and so on this is the
cause the sort of like Western arrogance
and lack of respect for for Russia
I wouldn't put it like that there is a
Western influence there which wasn't
very helpful and that happened in the
Yelchin period he had the major
liberalization of the market
and you had the privatization of the
nomenclature the old Soviet Elite uh
who'd basically managed to appropriate
for themselves all the states properly
all the state resources and essentially
uh ripped it off and private creation of
the oligarchy exactly so so people don't
often understand that the West was quite
complicit in the creation of the
oligarchy and I think in that sense uh
you know they probably imagined that
they would turn out to be you know good
old capitalists like a Rockefeller was
or whatever
but what they didn't really understand
is that by doing that he essentially
undercut the possibility of a genuine
democratic transition because he created
the basis for an oligarchical society
and an oligarchical State and
oligarchies in general in history are
very rarely open to democratic pressure
they're not going to be particularly
accountable so I think that was a
problem
opportunity was lost at that particular
moment in terms of you know having a
much more
um I would hands-off attitude but also I
think not encouraging this kind of
because a lot of the American other
companies went in there
to encourage the rise of the oligarchy
so I think that was a tragedy and I
think the second thing it's not so much
that Russia needed that a Marshall Plan
I think that there should be much more
of an effort to try to bring Russia into
NATO so for example I remember I I was
involved after 9 11 I was involved in a
NATO
um Consultant Group consisting of
westerners in Russia Russians
and we were discussing how to deal with
a common problem which was Global
Islamic Terror
which was as much a problem for them as
it was for the West
and we had no problem
uh cooperating
um obviously we had very different
interests and all that but I kind of
wish that we had created much more
much much more space where there could
have been uh sort of uh a kind of
dialogue going on which might have
limited the possibility of what
eventually then occurs where you have
the
unrestrained emergence of grievance
politics by Putin uh where she's he's
got a Russian identity politics is
allowed to flourish
and whether all that the West does is
kind of what it kind of watches that you
know sort of been
doesn't really understand that this is a
very very dangerous development but
surely Frank as well we didn't just
watch because I think it was uh during
Tony Blair's uh regime we allowed
billions of dirty Russian money to flow
into the city so we were we were also in
cahoots it was in our interests as well
well that's what I was getting at
earlier on I was talking about the
privatization or the Naman clatura yeah
because when you look at all the foreign
energy companies and the foreign
investment bankers and the way that
Foreign Service provided the big four
like KPMG all these all these big
organizations went into Russia because
the way they looked at it they could
clean up and they did really really well
out of that whole situation and they
created what they thought was just like
a comprador subservient oligarchical
class and not understanding that the
state
in essence had not changed all that much
it was privatized economically but
politically the the layers of the state
from the past were still in place
and although the you know the KGB might
have changed its name and all the
different institutions looked uh had a
different facade uh the fundamentals of
that state structure of that
authoritative structure remained behind
this liberalized you know sort of
economic Visage hey Francis do you like
locals I live in London Mike so
obviously not the only pleasure I get
from the locals is when we show an
intimate moment as we watch a Japanese
tourists get trapped in a tube door
guys kids but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal behind the
scenes content when you thank you
when you get lost incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew doors
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share means have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
and people don't actually understand
that you know at the higher levels
they're still you know just like in the
Soviet Union and in the Russian Empire
before there is no private property in
Russia the oligarchs don't own the
assets that they own they can be taken
away just like that if you displease the
Tsar or the president or whoever is the
general secretary
um but come back come back uh to
grievance politics and Russian identity
politics what are you talking about
Frank
well I think that uh what happened was
that uh many people
uh in the Russian Elite you know sort of
resented
the the fact that Russia was not going
to become a a second-rate regional power
rather than a global superpower
and they never got over the fact that
there was this massive change in the
status
even though between you and me even
before the end of the Cold War is
evident that Russian omnipotence was
more apparent than real it was a very
weak failed State even even before that
but nevertheless they could pretend that
you know it's us in the United States we
run the world and now all of a sudden
you wake up one morning
and you realize that you're just a you
know a large Regional power and I think
for for those people all those people
that came as a bit of a shock and they
basically began to uh sort of blame the
West for the predicament they were in
you know Russia always had this
interesting culture between the the
Russia fires and the Western you know
sort of people that wanted to make
Russia look like the West yeah go if you
read Dostoyevsky or tosto you will find
those uh elements already exist in 19th
century and I think at a certain point
that kind of uh animus against the West
converge with this attempt to create
this Russian this Russian Mystique
which then meant that it provided a
certain kind of ideological
understanding for them that somehow you
know we were robbed
and of course they were they were robbed
but they were robbed by themselves
rather than and of course by the West as
well but it's principally it was a
domestic accomplishment that has
constantly said what they ended up doing
was keep the state intact and then turn
this oligarchs into a modern high-tech
group of cultures you know who are there
the pleasure you know of Putin who have
who have whoever happens to be in power
but see this is why my have this issue
with this argument about the West
complicity I have no doubt that Western
corporations profited massively from the
collapse of the of the nation but is it
I mean the way I look at it someone who
grew up in Russia during that period is
is it the West fault that Russia the
Soviet Union lost the Cold War because
that's what we're really talking about
the resentment politics and the
grievance inevitably comes from loss of
status and loss of power which is
particularly an acute issue for Russians
they always have been obsessed with
their role in the world being powerful
is literally the number one objective
for as people in Russia think about it
is it our fault that we won the Cold War
here in the West well I mean if the
reality is that Russia
lost the Cold War a long time before it
did yes and that was because number one
it lost its moral Authority
that was already the case in the in the
stylist era where it's ideological and
moral appeal began to diminish
secondly it lost the Cold War because it
turned out in the 1970s that it had
reached a limit in economic terms it
couldn't really make the transition from
a heavy industry-based Society to one
that was technologically Superior you
couldn't really do that it could no
longer compete in any sense whatsoever
against the West in economic terms why
was that Frank
because in order to make the transition
from heavy industry to more
sophisticated technical technology you
need to have some kind of system of
incentive you need to have a much
greater freedom for people to experiment
than uh what's possible in the old
Soviet regime and the Syrian regime
could do uh you know build big roads and
Railway systems and heavy industry
because that just meant they could throw
a lot of labor at it you know hundreds
of thousands of people could be thrown
at it without necessarily having the
technological capacity to do this so the
Russian economy began to fall it looked
it still looked good because uh where
they wanted to do really well for
example in the nuclear sector or the
space technology sector they will
prioritize all their best people and all
their best resources to make sure that
those sectors of the economy worked but
it was at the expense of everything else
the basically you would you could be
have Sputnik you know being the first
one to go into space but if you go into
a shop in Russia you know you could you
couldn't get a watch that worked a
Russian watch Network or a lighter that
actually had you know could create
flames never mind just making noise so
that was the Paradox of the economy so
that came to an end in the 1970s and it
just so happened that when Reagan you
know turned the screws in terms of the
arms rivalry that was the end of the you
know and they knew that they already
knew that in you know even the members
was alive
that it was only a matter of time before
that was the end and the Russian style
is to lead themselves had stopped
believing in it and the way he knew that
was the case was because they began to
send their children to Oxford or to Yale
you know they all you know all got nice
Western degrees they weren't getting
going to University of Leningrad or or
Moscow they were all going to the west
and that was the beginning of the
privatization of this nomenclature
so Frank at the core of this is the the
the Russian leadership and the Chinese
leadership they talk a lot nowadays
about a multi-polar world you know we
don't want to live in a world that's
dominated by essentially the anglosphere
basically America plus right
um and that is what this is all about
isn't it
I think partially you have to remember
that
we don't live in a unipolar world
anymore because America
uh although it's probably the most
powerful economy even now at the moment
more powerful than China
and although it's got this incredible
soft power cultural influence all over
the world it is no longer hegemonic in
the way that it was in the past
so we are seeing the beginning of a
multi-polar world uh whereby you have
greater regionalism greater Regional
economic ties taking place anyway
and I think that what's happened is that
Russia and to a greater extent China
are trying to figure out how they could
insert themselves into this new world
and gain greater power China is on the
up at the moment people don't realize it
but it's doing remarkably well in
geopolitical terms it's cleaning up in
the South Pacific
for example I don't know if you heard
but there's a place called the Solomon
Island which used to be run by the
Australians and the Americans and the
chance just went in there bribed
everybody
and now they're like the dominant power
then America wakes up and realizes you
know much much too late look what has
happened China is very active in Latin
American in Africa it's very active in
Europe uh Australia I mean when you when
you go to Melbourne or you know any of
these places you'll you find that it's
got a massive influence there so we are
seeing a much more fragmented World
Order taking place and the really
important question that is indeterminate
at the moment is where where does Europe
fit in into all this to what extent can
Europe play a significant role because
at the moment Europe is allowing itself
to become The Bag Man for the United
States essentially uh it's not taking
any initiative at the same time it's
critic criticizing the Americans for you
know taking the initiative but it's not
doing anything that could possibly
resemble the Ambitions of a of anybody
who wants Global power but do you think
the problem is as well is that it feels
to me and you know far more about this
than I do but it feels to me like in the
west and in Europe in particular we're
more divided than ever we seem to be at
each other's throats you know it's
there's political turmoil happening
we're entering a cost of living crisis
all over Europe so I guess my question
too is Frank how can we possibly lead
the world when we can't even lead our
own countries well you know my book the
one of the main points in my book
is what I call the moral disarmament of
the West and I think that's for me is a
really crucial concept because what that
really gets at is that in the West
there is no commanding moral system of
authority no moral no moral imagination
where you're able to give your people a
sense of meaning about what it means to
be English or what it means to be French
or American
and I think what has happened is that
we've become detached from the past
we've talked about the loss of
historical sense and what you're left
with is this very narrow Outlook which
is a combination of technocratic
ambition and identity politics there are
only two things that are going at the
moment and what you're really describing
is probably the biggest challenge we
face because when you look at the United
States it's so polarized
people are so much at each other's
throats it is like going to two
different countries you know so when you
people literally don't talk to each
other anymore have you got a lot of that
here even in Britain but nothing in
nothing like the same intensity but
that's gradually spreading all over
Europe so that kind of internal division
uh work which is not mediated by a
common sense that this is where we are
and you know sort of is a huge problem
which is why I think as we're speaking
we got all this uh unusual reaction uh
about the Queen's death where suddenly
Queen Elizabeth becomes this you know
essentially she reminds us
the history does matter that there is
such a thing as a historical Legacy and
unless we take that seriously there's
nothing there's no soul on which we can
flourish as a society
and that's a real challenge for our
society like I said before because you
look at China and and you look at Russia
and it's far more easy from the outside
for them to be you for them to be
unified because they're totalitarian
regimes
whereas what you have with democracies
that you have changed and you have free
speech and you have partisanship it's
it's far more difficult isn't it to be
cohesive in those types of societies
up to a point I think you're right but I
I think there's a danger of uh
overstating the capacity of an
authoritarian Society like Russia or
China
to create this kind of homogeneous
Outlook it looks like that from the
outside but there are very important
internal tensions occurring there as
well and
the influence of the West is quite
important among sections of
Russian or Chinese Society there are
Regional differences and one of my fears
you know is not just simply what Russia
is doing in Ukraine
one of my fears is what will happen if
Russia implodes the Federation implodes
because
you know Russian Federation is by no
means as coherent and stable as it looks
I'm a lot of the republics you know sort
of exists within the Russian Federation
or
dying to get out of that Federation
they're all looking somewhere else no
they're not Russian ethnically foreign
very often etc etc which is one of the
things that started to happen in the 90s
which is why you end with end up with
Putin because the country's collapsing
tejner wants to separate it's just the
beginning and they are like we need to
find a strong man leader who's going to
crack down and hold the country together
um so what what do you what do you think
is going to happen with the war in
Ukraine and with Russia
well in the book I argue that this is a
typical Frontier War
and a frontier War usually means
that it that there are these uh inbuilt
long
historically rooted
uh source of attention
and the way that I look at it is that
for that reason I think this war is not
going to end anytime soon
because although there's no doubt will
be peace treaties and
you know sort of they will decide to
have cease fires and everything else
uh that's not going to happen because uh
this is a war that Ukraine
cannot win and Russia cannot afford to
lose
I think Ukraine came in a major moral
Victory it's already done that to some
extent it can hold on to all the
territory that
Russia tried to take away from it
but at the end of the day Ukraine is
Ukraine and it's not in a hasn't got the
power and the strength even with
Western support to inflict such a blow
on Russia
that it that would completely uh sort of
mean that that's that is really the end
so the way that I say that is that the
conflict is going to continue for some
time to come and
what we you know there's nothing we can
do about here and there because it
depends upon the people on the ground
all that we can do is
uh hope that somehow
a certain breeding space can be created
for the Ukraine to re-charge its battery
because it's losing a lot of people it's
uh you know it's losing a lot of its
resources
and hopefully uh sort of
as the global owner you know reorganized
itself
it might be a little bit more difficult
to start a new war and that's what I'm
really hoping for and uh
I think the key thing is
ensuring that everything is done
possible to make sure that
ukrainians in the Ukraine's Independence
and its capacity to be a Sovereign
Nation is upheld and protected
I think that's the key objective at the
same time I think that we could be wary
of the possibility of Russia
disintegrating
and the corrosive and explosive
consequences that will have in the
Caucasian and all the all the different
you know the Asian parts of of the
Federation which could be
could unleash a dynamic that will you
know you know kind of invite Iranian
bring in turkey and God knows what's
going to happen at that point
so we've touched on this and for there's
going to be a lot of people who are very
interested in this who've never had this
I've never even contemplated this
thought and I'm one of them why might
Russia implode and what are the
countries who want to break free of of
Russia
well I think that just about every
non-russian Republic
you know would rather
you know sort of move away at a distance
and even Armenia uh which often acts as
a Russian proxy state
uh even Armenia doesn't hasn't got a
love affair with with Moscow by any
means so the the way that I see it is
that
the Russian Federation is held together
by essentially a coercive authoritarian
means rather than through any kind of
consensus
and there are very few mechanisms for
consensus to be a cheese all done by
negotiations and bullying it's not that
kind of kind of combination
and what's happened in most recent
period is that turkey and Iran for very
different reasons are using its
influence to try to seduce and attract
people to move in their Direction
pretty much in the way that you know
sort of we had a comparable situation in
the Kosovo and elsewhere where you have
different Islamic Powers trying to sort
of gain a degree of influence if not
hegemony in that part of the world
so yeah I've got this very bad feeling
that if you have something like the a
com something like the Balkan War you
know Mark II but this time within the
Russian Federation
the consequences that will be much more
uh drastic dramatic than what happened
in in the old Yugoslavia and what might
those consequences be geopolitically
frank
well I think that uh the way that I I
mean one of the things I worry about is
that I will put Iran in a much stronger
position
because you know Iran's already been
made an honorary member of this club
that China
and Russia inhabits so there's kind of a
new triangular relationship that's been
established
I don't think that would be a very good
result if Iran strengthens its kind of
position and stabilizes itself process
at that time right between Iran things
are going awry I think that turkey is
very interesting in this respect because
turkey is on a roll at the moment
because it's needed by NATO
they need to really realize on turkey as
this intermediary
but at the same time turkeys got very
clear distinct interests
which fundamentally contradict that of
Europe and and and and European powers
so that's what I meant earlier on when
we talked about a situation not unlike
before first world war where we not very
simply don't know who's going to line up
with who under those circumstances
uh and I suppose the question because I
remember when the war in Ukraine first
when the Russia first invaded Ukraine
when that conflict began there were a
lot of very uh I hope they'll forgive me
for saying it's very naive people in the
west who were like what we just we just
need to get rid of Putin that's what we
need to do and and they thought that
that's that that would help uh and I was
always saying to them you do realize you
get rid of it it's probably not going to
be Nick Clegg that comes to power in
Russia do you know what I mean
um so either you're gonna get another
strong man leader who's gonna need to
assert himself even more to prove
himself because he's not Putin he hasn't
proven himself or there's the other
scenario which you're alluding to which
is he's not strong enough to hold the
Federation it's really an Empire what
Russia is today the Russian Empire
together
and then you get the disintegration of
this country which has an awful lot of
nuclear weapons
you're right and I think what the
tragedy is and this goes back to the
point about geopolitical illiteracy is a
lot of people have a psychological
interpretation of the war that Putin is
just a mad person and if you remove that
kind of cancerous growth on Russian
Society then it'll be really cool not
realizing that uh
you know you can't blame the war on this
single individual there's a whole system
that played there it's a lot of uh
interests that are work and if Putin is
taken out then somebody else will
replace him who might uh smile a little
bit more than Putin does but essentially
things will pretty much remain the same
and I do think this naivety is very very
unhelpful this single-minded Focus
on an individual or a small number of
individuals rather than the fact that
there's a whole
system imperial system that that's
running that society that have got a
common interest in maintaining the
status quo so that being the case then I
hear what you say about Ukraine Ukraine
should be given the support it needs to
remain independent and hopefully things
calm down over time even though they're
they're very strong pre-existing
interest from both sides that are in
conflict
what should the West do what should we
do in this country what should the
Americans do what should Europe do uh in
order to
manage this crisis which is from what
you're saying it's really a global
crisis that's what's Happening Here what
should the West do to mitigate some of
the consequences of what's Happening
well in the end it doesn't it's not in
the hand of the West entirely in the
beginning of the war I got a lot of
criticism
because I argued for example that we
should basically tell Russia to uh
neutralize the airspace so that
basically Russia couldn't control the
air unilaterally and indicate that the
West will have a you know sort of the
West you know should have you know will
be sending in airplanes with you know
military supplies
if not in the hole you can at least draw
lines so that you know west of Kiev you
would have
you know sort of the a kind of a a no-go
area where this could be done I got a
lot of criticism for saying that I'm
just escalating the war and they will
make things a little bit more difficult
well not a little bit more difficult
people would have said you're starting
world war three that's really that's
what they were exactly a little bit more
difficult but you see Frank it's so
British now that's that's his definition
the end of the world is a little bit
more difficult yeah I've kind of learned
the English understated yes yeah yeah
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so I was accused of being a warmonger
and you know and I and the point that I
made was that if you basically argue
that every time you help Ukraine it kind
of creates the risk of a nuclear war
then you might as well give up because
what is saying that uh you know Russia's
nuclear blackmail is going to have the
last word on everything
and I still think that but but not that
the war has gone on for so long
what I'm really worried about is that uh
the nature of the war has changed quite
dramatically and somehow or another you
know sort of we need to kind of take a
step back and find how we can limit the
damage that's being created uh within
Ukraine itself I I do worry about the
consequences of this for Ukrainian
Society in the long run because they
need a bit of breeding space and
stability in order to rebuild and get
their act together so you know that
seems to me to be the key thing I think
the West
you know people in the west should be
fighting for a
the creation of I suppose a lack of a
better expression a red line
that Russia knows that they must not
cross as a way of indicating that you
know the Russian knows that if they
cross the red line there'll be a
external intervention but within that
it's going to be resolved by the
Ukrainian people themselves with our
support well I don't want to lecture the
ukrainians and then what to do no no of
course but I was asking about the West
because the West is the deciding factor
I would argue Frank because if the West
doesn't help Ukraine Ukraine will
collapse in a day and if the West wanted
to for Ukraine to win you say Ukraine
can't win actually Ukraine could win if
the West provided what it needs to win
whether the West wants to do that is a
different conversation but I suppose the
perhaps there are more optimistic
scenarios you we talked very early on in
the conversation you mentioned that
Ukraine never really had a strong
national identity there was a strong
ethnic identity but not a national
identity I'd argue
we're starting to see the formation of a
very strong National Ukrainian identity
so while of course they're taking losses
and the economies being damaged and the
industrial the heartlands are also to
some extent being affected by the war
this could be the beginning of the
emergence of an actual country called
Ukraine
um which if it is given the support it
needs to be part of the EU or to be some
sort of NATO Ally or something like that
it could be just a normal country
eventually couldn't it well I have big
hopes for Ukraine becoming a normal
country and you're right to suggest that
as a result of this experience
there's an unusual degree of domestic
solidarity between Ukraine and there's a
kind of even a certain cultural you know
sounds that is occurring that yeah you
can see which is really
very nice to see and by the way just
sorry to interrupt there is a a mending
of the thing that was always at the
heart of Ukrainian society which is
Western Ukraine and Eastern Ukraine the
Russian speakers and and the Ukrainian
speakers the people like to exaggerate
the differences between the two they're
not as big as people like to believe but
nonetheless that
that doesn't exist anymore in anything
like the way that it did right well it
still exist but not as you say not in
the way that it did and there's been a
kind of coming together
uh as a result this of this common
experience so I think that all that is
true where I slightly disagree with you
is I don't think that the West can win
the war for Ukraine yeah because there
are real limits as to what the West can
do
given the fact that there are you know
if it goes beyond a certain point
then we are talking about such an
escalation uh that would that the West
would find Unthinkable I mean I think
the West is not known for its courage
and its bravery and its Spirit of
sacrifice
and I cannot see you know I cannot see
the West doing very much more you know
my my objective
as far as the West is concerned is to
make sure that uh its support its
economic and Military Support for
Ukraine is not compromised in the medium
term and and and and that kind of War
weary sentiment that's begin to kick in
in many parts of Europe is to some
extent contained and and there's not a
lot to undermine the support that
Ukraine is getting I think that's that's
what we should be hoping for and and
fighting for in the current ERA and the
problem as you touched on before Frank
with Ukraine is that obviously Ukraine
can't lose because they're literally
fighting for their country they're
fighting for their lives but Putin can't
lose either he can't lose face well
exactly exactly throw around in the book
notice I can't afford to lose
which is why uh it seems to me that this
is a war that's going to go on for a
long long long time at a certain point
you know something is going to happen in
in the global dynamic that will
essentially till the balance
in such a way that the the conflict has
a chance of being resolved but I think
that don't don't think that's gonna
happen just yet because at the moment
everybody is literally positioning and
even you know we talk about the West
helping Ukraine but there's almost like
a vulture-like approach where different
European countries are looking for
opportunities in this world it's not
like everybody's altruistically decided
that we're just going to help Ukraine
regardless of its consequences people
are looking for
you know sort of their own interest and
they're asking the question well what's
in it for us you know sort of in that
kind of real politic uh is never far
from this under the surface as at the
moment
and it's also you know like you said we
are politics but you know there's also
people making money out of this as well
absolutely yeah and this is this is very
much the case you know sort of uh and
there's been a lot of discussions about
the way in which
you know under the radar
trade is still going on with Russia you
know sort of under the radar
you know people are profiteering from
the arms and the various resources and
supplies that we're that's being sent to
the Ukraine so it's it is just like any
other War you know there is a kind of
surface form of patriotism altruism and
heroism but under the surface
the you know the war profiteering and
the uh and the hustling and everything
else that still still goes on because
we're also energy dependent on on Russia
certainly you know not so much our
country but Germans etc etc they they
need
Russian energy have you got to
understand that I mean you have to
remember that there's a danger that if
things go the way they are the German
economy German industry
is simply going to disintegrate I mean
there's already if you look at the uh
the German economy the middle level
a sort of multinational factories are
really being hit very very hardly on the
small factories that are employing five
six hundred people or many of them are
being are forced to close down
so there is a obviously a cost to this
and I mean the Germans did this to
themselves absolutely yeah absolutely no
I'm I'm I haven't got very much sympathy
I'm just simply saying that they are in
a predicament yes and that's going to
limit
their flexibility and their willingness
to do the right thing
Frank let me ask you something that
a lot of people will find a strange
question but I do think is at least a
valid question to ask that's normally
what I do mate yeah it's true
um
would we be here
without all of this
identity politics
this internal strife and division every
time an American president gets elected
either he was put there by the Russians
or it was a fake election or whatever
would we be having a war in Ukraine if
the West hadn't just started obsessing
about all this stuff
it's a very good question and a very
difficult one to answer
I think that
if the if this was a different world
and if we had a stronger sense of
purpose and a stronger sense of who we
are a greater belief in democracy and
sovereignty in a essentially in Western
culture and Western real life then I
think that Western societies will be far
more formidable uh rather than being so
weak internally and that would have made
people think twice you have to remember
that there are many people in Moscow and
Beijing you know who go who look at the
United States in particular
and they see
tension and conflict and they see an
army that spends more time you know sort
of messing around trying to figure out
its pronouns then you know sort of
taking its military Mission seriously
you know they look at America and they
find that this is a post-heroic age yes
where courage is conspicuously absent in
in terms of the values of American
society and one of the points I try to
make in the book is that a lot of people
in Europe you know sort of particularly
Germans but also others they look at the
Iranians and they ask themselves the
question if we were invaded
you know with our people you know sort
of fight back the way the ukrainians did
would they have the capacity
to withstand that level of shock and
attack and a lot of people are saying
that in their hearts of Hearts they
don't think that they would I looked at
a survey
of every single European country and the
story asked the question would you fight
against a foreign invader
that was the question they asked do you
know which was the country that had the
highest response rate that they would
fight and the idea no it was Finland yes
and that's understandable that makes
sense yeah they've done it before
they've done it before it makes perfect
sense yeah and then you have the low end
you know it would be like the Dutch you
know no jokes about Dutch courage or
anything like that but yeah it was the
Dutch and the more kind of Cosmopolitan
you know kind of Nations and I think
that when you when you kind of look at
this this goes back to my point but
moral disarmament when you morally
disarm
you know as and and the first time we
ever used the term moral disarmament was
in relation to France in the 1930s but
it just basically gave up you know sort
of allowed the Germans to walk into
Paris you know kind of more or less when
you kind of morally disarm in the way
that we did then being able to
militarily and physically re-arm or or
or be or be firm is is problematic I
mean I hope I'm wrong
well this is what uh I made this point
the day the invasion happened in my
opinion it would never have happened if
we hadn't spent the last six years
obsessing about stuff that didn't really
matter
um but I have been heartened by the West
response actually and I suppose the
question for me is has this been the
wake-up call that we needed because I
don't believe that Vladimir Putin is
sitting in the Kremlin now going this
has gone the way I wanted right I I
think you overestimated the weakness in
division of the West I think he
overestimated uh the the reaction that
he would receive both from within
Ukraine and from externally is it
possible that this is the spark the West
needed to sort of wake up and go maybe
we shouldn't make ourselves energy
dependent on people who are uh at least
adversaries let's put it that way right
this is maybe the moment we go okay look
globalization was great for a while but
it's not working in this current climate
we've got to have food security we've
got to have energy security we've got to
have actual security we gotta be willing
to to work in the different way in this
new world and part of that means we've
got to stop obsessing about stuff that
doesn't matter and deal with it do you
think that's possible
possible but if if you kind of roll the
film backwards when the war broke out
Putin's assessment of the West is
actually correct
because if you remember the initial
reaction in the weeks leading up to the
invasion and and on the day of division
was we don't really want to help the
ukrainians too much because the war is
going to be finished in a couple of
weeks true it's pointless true and I've
got the in the book I mentioned all
these people you know the the German
government basically telling the
Ukrainian Ambassador we're not going to
help you because in a couple of weeks
you know there's not going to be a
Ukraine so you had this very kind of
cowardly you know sort of extremely
opportunistic reaction by the West not
by Britain no Britain was you know
Britain was The Honorable exception but
the two good countries in this drama at
that point are Britain and Poland
yeah yeah and then what happens is that
when people in the west see that the
ukrainians are fighting you know that
they're not rolling over and and that
contrary to their expectation the
Russian army is making one blunderous
mistake after another
suddenly what you have is a situation
where every Western leader wants to hang
out in Kiev you know sort of and wants
to take these pictures with the
Ukrainian president and at that point
what you have is Ukraine becomes what I
call a kind of a a medium to which
Western leaders try to gain legitimacy
you know and and because look
authoritative standing next to him it's
a little bit parasitic because they are
being parasitic on what the ukrainians
are doing and then when Biden sees that
Russia is in big trouble
that's at that point that the West
starts coming together and NATO is
reinvented because NATO was a zombie
organization beforehand so NATO is
reinvented as this you know sort of
credible Force Europe begins to uh in a
sense
talk with greater Unity than previously
not completely and then you have this
apparent solidity the solidarity in the
west which is I I still think it's more
apparent than real but uh give them
credit where it's due I think at that
point people feel that on balance
supporting Ukraine at this particular
moment in time is for a better choice to
make than just holding back in the way
we're doing beforehand
however I think you know so where
constantly you really are right
is that because of all of what really
happened
globalization not globalization but
globalist ideology becomes no longer
credible you have the fragmentation of
of regions and the
reinsertion of pride in the nation and
National sovereignty and the recognition
than in economic terms you know you
cannot rely on God or somebody in
America to provide you with food and
energy or even with vaccines you gotta
attend to those things yourself and I
think that has really created a much
greater understanding that the nation
isn't just unimportant as it was argued
earlier on the national borders do
matter and that we have to be much more
self-sufficient than we were beforehand
and that's creating an interesting you
know sort of global dynamic where
essentially we're going to have much
greater emphasis on regions looking
after each other and divisional labor
established with individual settings and
that might you know sort of cross your
fingers crossed create a greater
awareness of the of a sovereign
political Outlook and also the kind of
moral values that are usually associated
with patriotism and commitment to your
nation I think that would be a really
positive thing and you can see a bit of
that I was in Finland recently and I
just love the fact that all these young
kids volunteering to join this Reserve
arm everybody's signing up you know and
I think that that kind of attitude if
you see a bit more of that could not be
you know could be a really really good
development because what will happen
Frank if we take the easy way out or the
cowards way out or however way you want
to say it and we don't give Ukraine the
support that it needs what do you think
will happen then
I think what would happen is that uh
Russia well if that would have happened
obviously Russia
would begin to imagine that it can
recreate the alto borders and that would
have all kinds of negative consequences
in the Baltic states it would have
negative consequences in east Europe but
more importantly it would send out the
signal that uh
you know what really matters is your
power your might rather than anything
else and I think that that would then
create a situation
where you know Wars and the
militarization of the global environment
would gain much greater traction than is
the case at the moment
my big worry at the moment is not Russia
you know I mean Russia is Russia and uh
you know
fortunately I'm not living in Riga or
Talent
um well my big worry is the way that our
society is you know Britain and
elsewhere
have kind of lost their way which is why
the book is really about how the West
lost their way and and the way in which
they simply have forgotten what they are
what they're about and and not having a
robust sense of national purpose I think
that's what haunts me all the time yeah
me too which is why I do hope this is
the spark that we've needed to wake up
from us cheaper and I think some people
are starting to realize we don't live in
the magical rainbow unicorn world that
we've sort of been dreaming in for the
last 30 years and it's it's been a
luxury and a privilege that we've had uh
it's been a great few decades for for
actually most of the world frankly
however in order to maintain that world
you have to be willing to stand up for
it and we haven't been so I hope that's
what happens Frank it's been a great
conversation I hope everybody gets the
book here is the road to Ukraine
um as always we've got one final
question before we do our questions for
my supporters on locals uh what is the
one thing that we're not talking about
in our society that we really should be
in your opinion well the one issue I
feel very passionate about and resent
that it's never actually discussed in
its own terms is the way that we're
infantilizing our society and the way
that adults are encouraged to behave
like children and the way that children
are adulterified and we kind of that
boundary between adulthood and child is
lost
so what we have is a situation where we
have a lot of biologically mature people
but who are essentially not encouraged
to take themselves seriously and have
that sense of moral and intellectual
Independence that we need and we need
that precisely
for dealing with the challenges that
we've been discussing because this is
very much a grown-up issue and our
children or people who behave childishly
are not going to be in a position
to give a lead or to sort of fight back
against all the bad and negative
developments that are kicking in our
world
Frank it's been a pleasure if people
want to find you online if they want to
get the book where's the best place to
do that well the book can get on Amazon
and otherwise I got a sub stack Frank
Freddy
can't come and also got a frankfuradi
website perfect Frank thank you so much
for joining us and thank you guys for
watching and listening we will see you
very soon with another brilliant episode
like this one or also all of them go out
at 7 pm UK time and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
nowadays we do seem more risk-averse and
we seem to be less Innovative is this
due to changes in society family
education child rearing and also the
loss of religious faith